in both these cases the question you're
being asked is graph and I take it I get
it
graphing access is another part of your
brain but it's fine like man you're
still using that part of my brain very
much right we need to change that
because graphing is central to the way
that tuna and extension 1 what how old
ideas fit together how do we wrap what I
want you to remember if every time you
seen absolute value going back to the
very first time we wrote the definition
absolute value of a is this thing ok I'm
gonna do that here and then we're just
going to follow the results in place of
writing the absolute value which is kind
of like a shorthand I'm going to expand
it all out it will become much longer to
write and quite come to some honest
thing however I can actually work with
it so started that thing is don't have
$2 in it so I'm not gonna muck with it
however when I moved to the next pub
there are two cases two versions at this
time right
there's this one sometimes the absolute
value X plus 1 is just X plus 1 when is
that when X plus 1 is positive for 0 so
this is what I would write ok I'm
reading in shorthand
that's when X is greater than negative 1
okay but I write it like that to make a
clear break up
that's one moment then there's the other
version it's going to be not just
regular X plus 1 but negative x plus 1
okay however I know this is a minus sign
already hanging out the front right so
that negative and the minus sign become
plus okay so this is the other version
of absolute value X of 1 if X plus 1 is
negative you with me so far
now let me just point out I said before
you know this is the one way you don't
worry about negative signs I don't like
that as a definition because clearly you
must worry about negative signs right
and then we'll prepare if they have part
of the question so it's not just that
they disappear just be careful with the
definitely
okay now that I've gotten rid of the
absolute value signs I can actually
collect some like terms so again draw my
- maybe place with two lines on it -
lots of this take away one now why don't
you get that
you just have X plus one so that's what
about the second row 2x plus one and
then another one that's three of them
right so I guess I could write that in
expanded form that's three outside of X
if I've got the abacus okay
algebraically I'm pretty happy I think
there's anything else I can do
so now we draw this back I'm from a set
of axes here now some textbooks some
places that they say that there's a
particular point at which everything
changes and that often but not always
called the critical point criticals a
bit of a catch-all word it just means
importance so different people use it in
different contexts which I am just
generally an overweight but sometimes we
key them will use these what they mean
the point where everything changes for
this is clearly x equals negative 1 x
equals negative 1 that's what he
switches over from this guy to this guy
okay so I'm gonna put mean x equals
negative 1 oh crap
now I'm going to left fix the box three
X plus three
it's very very steep and this means it's
being shifted vertically upwards great
now it would pass through three if I
went through there but I don't because
remember the left-hand side but if I
folded it down back where it comes from
surprise surprise it's going to
intersect with anyone
like so you came that's nice to sneak
because of the gradient but I've written
up you so this is that much
okay I've done one half is not so
difficult what about the other this that
X is greater than negative 1 what's it
gonna do can you describe its gradient
positive negative it's gonna be going up
not various it's not the earliest it's
this but it's sort of gonna hear one do
you agree that's it you're done and look
we data to dating before but if you are
patient with it and you take it down to
size thank you
that's all you know it no big deal